Ever notice how when you're
searching for funny movies
or cake recipes,
you click on a link,
you look at these suggestions,
and you're like, meh.
So you go back.
You click on another link.
You look at the
suggestions there,
and it just takes forever.
It's a bit annoying, isn't it?
Why is that?
Because what you're
searching for is things.
And, in fact you're
getting links.
What if instead you got
organized visual results
to help you spot the thing
that you wanted right away?
That would be neat, right?
We thought so.
So for this type of
category queries,
we're changing Search to show
more things and fewer links.
I am Mariya, and
these are Rich Cards.
Rich Cards are building on
the success of rich snippets.
They present
categories of content
in beautiful visual
carousels that you
can scroll left and
right with images
and other interesting
information.
As a developer, it's
a great opportunity
if you present your
content in this way
because you can stand
out in the results
and attract more
visitors to your site.
You also take up
more space, and you
can add more elements
from your on-page content
to the Search Result page.
Today I'll show you how to
get your things into Search
for users who are
looking for them.
So how does this work?
To get your content
displayed as a Rich Card,
you need to add
schema.org and JSON-LD
to the relevant
bits of your site.
First, you need to find out if
your content matches the Rich
Card verticals.
Verticals are listed
in the gallery.
We've built up screenshots.
We have code samples.
We have different examples.
So you can browse there.
You can have a look and
see what actually matches
what you have on your site.
And then also, each
code sample has a link
to the Structured
Data Testing tool
so that you can tweak
the code in real time
and see what happens
to the examples.
After you've figured
out which vertical
is most representative of your
content, what you need to do
is find the essential
things to mark up.
Each type of Rich
Card has fields,
without which we cannot
display it in Search.
So, for example, for recipes,
that's name and image.
But you can add more fields to
make your cards richer and more
attention-grabbing
than everything else
that we show in the
Search Results page.
Again, for recipes,
you can add calories.
You can add preparation time.
You can add ingredients.
And you can even add ratings.
So here, side-by-side,
you can see the basic card
with only name and image marked
up, and then an enhanced card
with ratings and
preparation time.
So you can see yourself
which one you would click on.
Now let's get down to
business and add some markup.
We recommend using JSON-LD
because it's an easy format
to use, especially if
you're using a Tag Manager.
It saves you tweaking
time when you
have to change the source
code of individual pages.
But, of course, your
implementation on your site
will depend on the type
of content management
system you're using.
Once you've got
your initial markup,
you can test it in the
Structured Data Testing tool,
and you immediately
see any errors,
like missing fields
or syntax issues.
Input either the markup
of a URL or the page with
marked up content into the
Structured Data Testing tool.
If there are any errors, you
will see them immediately
in the tool UI.
In our case, there's
a missing image field.
Once you add the
missing image field,
then everything
checks out, and you
can use the Preview
function in order
to see how this Rich
Card will actually
appear in search results.
Once you're happy with the
final state of your markup,
you need to deploy it across the
different pages of your site.
One easy way that
I'm going to show you
here is to use
Google Tag Manager.
But, again, depending on
how your site is set up,
you might have to
use other approaches.
So, in our case, we go
to Google Tag Manager,
we create a custom tag, and then
we input the JSON-LD in there,
in the space for the tag.
And after that you
can pick if you
want to deploy it as across all
the pages of your site or just
a specific set.
You can pick individual
pages, or you
can use regular expressions
to catch specific patterns.
And once that's
ready, every time
your page loads,
Google Tag Manager
will also load the
necessary JSON-LD
so that you have the structured
markup on each of your pages.
So now you've done
all the markup.
Your pages are
getting processed.
What do you want to know?
You want to know what you're
getting out of this, right?
So the place to go to find
this out is Search Console.
Search Console is
a free tool that
knows all the stats
about how your site is
doing in Search, including your
Rich Cards, if you have any.
First, you have to verify
that you're an owner,
and then you will
see every detail
that we know about
your Rich Cards,
including how many were
indexed, how many have errors,
and how many are just fine.
So one good question
to ask yourself here
is, the ones that are indexed
and reported in Search Console,
are they approximately
the same number as the one
that you originally
marked up and submitted?
If not, then you might have
an issue with discovery.
Meaning that Google can't
find all of your pages
and process them.
One way to solve this is
by submitting a sitemap.
A sitemap is
basically an XML file
which has a list of
the URLs that you
want to submit to
Google for discovery
and has some metadata
about each URL.
So you can easily generate
this with a third-party tool
and then upload it
through Search Console.
And this will help
us find out about all
of your pages that have markup.
Another issue that
you might encounter
is that we're not showing
some of your Rich Cards
in Search because
they have errors.
And I'm talking
here specifically
about the required
fields that are missing,
or maybe the syntax
is wrong for them.
So we'll show you all of
those in the same report,
in the Rich Cards report.
And you can see them grouped
first by markup type,
and then by error type.
So you can drill
down, pick a category,
and take a few examples.
Then you can examine the code.
Each URL has a direct link to
the Structured Data Testing
tool, where you can tweak
the markup, fix the errors,
and see exactly how you need to
change this across your site.
As you deploy to fix and we
start re-indexing those pages,
you'll see the number of
errors in the Rich Card report
go down, down, down as
we're re-indexing each page
and adding more Rich Cards.
So now you know how to
keep track of coverage
and also how to
get rid of errors.
The next and the more
interesting question
is, how much traffic are you
getting from all these Rich
Cards?
So another place that you can
look in order to find this
is Search Analytics
Report in Search Console.
And we've added
there a filter that
allows you to look
at only the clicks
and impressions
specifically for Rich Cards,
and here's how to
filter down to that.
Now, here you'll
find information
on queries, impressions, clicks,
average position, top pages,
anything you want to know
about how your Rich Card
content is doing in Search.
This is also a
really useful place
that you can derive data
for finding opportunities
to grow your traffic
and attract more users.
One thing that you can do is
compare your Rich Card queries
and impressions with
everything that you get
for known marked up content.
And maybe you will identify
some portion of your content
that you can mark up and
make it even more attractive
in search results and
that way get more traffic.
Another thing that you
could do is also go back
to the Rich Cards Report and
look at your enhanceable cards.
Those are cards where you've
done correctly all the markup
for the required fields,
but you could do some more
and mark up more fields to
make the cards even more
eye-catching.
So having that and
then comparing it
to the query information
in Search Analytics
can help you see where it's
worth the effort to invest
a little bit more in marking
up different types of content.
So now you know
what Rich Cards are,
how to implement them,
how to debug errors,
and how to keep
track of the traffic
that you're getting after they
start showing up in a search.
If you want to find out
more for specific verticals,
including the examples
and the code snippets,
you'll find everything
on the Developer Site.
And once you've done all
the work to implement them,
you can keep track of how
you're doing in Search console
after you verify your site.
Thanks for watching,
and good luck.
[MUSIC PLAYING]